let's get to that first story ladies and
gentlemen here we go
jury wraps up first day of deliberations
in jessie smilet's trial for alleged
hoax hate crime and it was funny we were
all sitting here and i pulled the story
up and i yelled out they didn't convict
him
and then ian was like wait what really
and i'm like no no i just mean
immediately like i mean like they
actually went home for the day because i
would have assumed it was going to be
cut and dry justice millet he did it he
staged a hoax hate crime lock him up
throw away the key luke made a good
point that he has six charges so that's
probably why they're taking so long they
got to figure out for each charge what's
going on did they overcharge him have
you guys been watching it has it been
like broadcast it now no but i've been
watching the tweets people talking about
what's going on and i think in chicago
they don't allow cameras i've i've
reported from uh juries uh from from uh
courtroom proceedings in chicago you
basically have to go in listen write
stuff down run out and then tweet and
then run back in is it a federal case it
is right no it's state level oh okay
yeah well that's also what you have to
do in the federal court proceedings and
that's why a lot of people have been
relying on twitter and people's twitter
accounts to find out what's happening in
the galen maxwell case which yeah well
we're going to talk about it a little
bit but for this particular case i mean
there's a lot of charges we're still
waiting to see what they're going to
deliberate on some people are saying
that he was overcharged but
obviously there's a lot of things
weighing here a lot of people are paying
attention to this
and there's a lot of interesting news
surrounding don lemon who also is being
accused of some very serious accusations
and faces his own kind of trial uh
upcoming as well but this is the big
part right here
in closing arguments special prosecutor
dan webb accused smilet of lying under
oath he laid out six key pieces of
evidence he said proved the actor
planned the fake attack with the
assistance of bola and ola osandyro two
acquaintances from the show he was
hoping those endiro brothers would not
cooperate with police he got exposed and
now we're in a trial
that's that's that's something we were
we were all glued to the written house
trial we know some of those people were
up there lying
no one said anything about it not even
the defense
now we have the prosecutor outright just
being like he's perjuring himself
so the prosecutor might actually bring
perjury charges
what kind of sentence is he facing if
he's convicted on this well i can't tell
you not a lawyer what i can say is it's
uh six counts of disorderly conduct but
they're they're felonies he's pleaded
not guilty so i'll put it this way some
people have said dude's not gonna get
prison time for this because he's like a
celebrity he's rich it's a first offense
it's a silly political thing and i'm
like i don't know how much time he'll
spend behind bars if any but he'll be a
felon he can't travel internationally
anymore or he'll struggle to can't own a
gun can't vote yeah so that ends his
career that ends
basically his life in a lot of ways this
is the kind of thing where you make a
fake accusation and you're trying to
frame somebody and you're trying to
cause something bad happen to somebody
else in general was it was there like a
victim here the victim was what just him
troubles himself it was just him trying
to get attention the victim was trump
supporters right just in general and
trump's character right and it's
remarkable
how many people just were willing to and
wanted to believe
that there were two big old trump
supporters downtown chicago at 2am who
saw the lone you know gay black actor
from empire and and were using that
against him and it's just the it's the
most ridiculous story and and and nobody
believes it right the funny thing is
when the story first comes out people
had a little bit of of like even even i
think a lot of people on the right were
like
could that have happened like that
sounds like bs but i want to see more
right then we'll jump to conclusions and
then it was very obvious i was like oh
this dude staged the whole thing well
the corporate media was selling this lie
like it was hot kicks they loved this
story he was on abc news being
interviewed crying on national
television the anchor was calling him a
national hero and everyone was making
the points online especially the blue
check marked individuals especially a
lot of celebrities if you don't believe
this story you're racist you're just as
bad as the people who attacked him which
is absolutely freaking ridiculous and it
took people just asking some questions
like hey how did this how did this
really unfold because some of the
details don't make sense here the police
started investigating it and then there
were some people in the media who
probably had police sources that were
tipping him off during this
investigation that the police weren't
believing him because the police had no
reason to believe him he didn't want to
take a dna test he didn't want to hand
over his cell phone he didn't want to
you know bring forward evidence
providing that he's innocent and
throughout this entire hearing i don't
think he did i think his only defense
that people are are talking about that i
have seen is that he has a personal
lifestyle that includes doing things
with with other dudes and and that's
that's what he was saying and understand
and i'm like that's not an argument that
doesn't prove any thing that you want to
prove here at all jack have you been
watching the trial or looking into it a
little bit i have not really it's just
sort of below my radar of like high
value things the only thing i'm really
interested in about it is like how how's
kamala harris going to react after she
like very publicly was in support of
this she going to retract that kind of
stuff of course not so i'm not going to
say anything but that's below my radar
really but the the defense here has been
absolutely hilarious it seems like their
defensive strategy was to like throw a
pie in the face of the court like
literally the defense comes in honking
and throws a pie and then runs away so
you had the defense attorney claim the
judge lunged at her and then uh
nearly in tears like ran out of the
courtroom with her mother i'm not like
legit like justice millett's defense was
arguing with the judge demanding a
mistrial claimed the judge lunged at her
and then got the the mistrial request uh
motion denied and then the new york post
reported she was nearly in tears as she
her and her mother who was in the
gallery left together and i was just
like this is insane justice malet
accused the process or scolded the
prosecutor for saying the n-word because
he was reading a text message
that's their plan
so everybody looking at this is like
dude is gonna go to jail is he still
purporting that he was attacked by two
faceless no no he said it was the
brothers oh yeah he was like well
actually i think he's i they said
initially that the osendera brothers
were sophisticated criminals or
something that were homophobes right
that hated him because he was gay
meanwhile the story came out that he had
relations with them
this seems like a like a coming together
of both the the anti-trump hate and
anti-maga hate and just like the clout
economy right like that people stage
things all the time they go to like
suicide forest they make dumb things
happen they create all kinds of like
spectacles in order to get attention
this do you do you think that the guy
just was like
all right maybe he just went one step
over the line in terms of the cloud
economy and like trying to just fake
attention for himself yeah i mean
several steps long jumped over the line
he like you know he sized it up he ran
he made the leap and then he stuck his
legs out he was really trying to get as
far past it as possible he's like an
example of um the insanity that culture
has reached like he's a young insane guy
thinking that this is no this is
acceptable have you have you seen the um
what are they called altars have you
seen this there's a subreddit called um
what is it called fake disorders or
something
and there's a bunch of people on tick
tock who have fake
i saw this and then there's there's a
woman and it's like an altar meaning
they create
creatures or things in their minds that
like can take over their body or
something and then they there's one
video that's that's on reddit right now
where the woman runs outside and is
doing like a smeagle dance in the rain
and squeaking and squealing while people
are like oh and then she comes inside
that's crying saying she didn't know
that rain was wet
there's a ton of videos like this
there's the one video where this this
young woman is like
i am a doll my name is doll i am doll
self and then like one eye just like
moves
and then she's like i am an alter and
then they have they have another thing i
forgot it's called but it's like a mind
companion where they create a fictional
person in their brain they talk to
so like maybe these aren't fake
disorders what i think we're seeing with
with like in the context of jessie
smilet like you were saying all of these
these things are converging into a
singularity as it were creating like
this weird combination of fake you know
victimhood
fake mental illnesses social media clout
all of these things swirling together
and now you have this absolute insanity
smellet wintha i'm gonna stage an attack
and get the police involved route other
people just run around like smeagle from
lord of the rings like oh in the rain
and it works they get clicks singularity
where have i heard that before
now also when you were bringing up the
disorders on social media the first
thing that i uh thought about were some
of the tick talkers that were pretending
to be at oswitch i don't know if you
remember things
yes they were tick-tockers they were
like imperials of them pretending to be
in auschwitz and being victims uh
portraying that so so this is a symptom
of a larger cause and effect by big tech
social media and the algorithms that are
literally promoting victimhood as power
in our modern day society and i think
that's why jesse smulet in part was
pushed in a way and kind of motivated
and manipulated by big tech
not literally but because of the actions
and because of the cultures that they
set that that he was kind of looking at
this as a way to position himself better
in society by by uh representing himself
as a victim wouldn't it have been better
for him to like set a building on fire
and put a woman up on the top floor and
then like have himself like sprinting
all the way up the stairs and grabbing
her and like jumping out into the into
the like savings that's toxic
masculinity
like the old days
a woman's gonna save you
i got a better way a better example of
how to explain what's happening with
this stuff have you seen those videos
where it's like these three women who
are you know really excited and they
walk into the kitchen and she's like
just wait just wait watch and then she
dumps like a gallon of milk on the
counter and it splatters everywhere and
then she like pours chocolate syrup and
starts mashing it with her hands and
she's like it's so great oh wow wow and
then she smears it all over the counter
and then puts like graham crackers on it
and she's like there it is you've not
seen these videos i have yeah you've
seen them there's one stomach was
turning where she takes a bunch of
cheeseburgers and puts them in a blender
and then mashed it to a paste and then
like puts it in a pan and she's like
this is so amazing there's one where she
takes spaghetti out of the pot dumps it
on her counter pours sauce all over the
counter she's mixing with her hands on
the counter and she's like it's going to
be so great now people can just come in
and eat it right off the counter there's
another one where she does it with chips
she pours chips all over the counter
pours nacho cheese all over it
these videos are interesting at least
she knows how to clean apparently right
right but check it out these videos are
intentionally off-putting and disgusting
why because people share it going this
is off-putting and disgusting so they do
this video where they're serious where
it's like they mix nasty foods in the
blender and then she's there's one it's
like she's squirting ketchup in the
blender with burgers and blending it up
and acting like it's a real thing
people click on this stuff they share it
three or three girls one spaghetti bowl
yeah apparently i saw what kind of
videos are you watching there jack but
look i see these videos and i know
exactly what they're doing and why
they're doing it yeah they found a way
to go viral yeah in in all the noise and
it works and they make money now what's
going to happen is that young people are
going to see this thinking it's real
like an adult can see that and discern
this is a manipulation attempt no one
would really do something so dumb let's
let's think about that for one second so
in your high school in the old days
there was always a couple or three or a
group of people who were like freaky and
would do freaky things and that would
get them attention right you would
definitely note the person that did the
weird thing with the hair and the paper
clip in the ear and the whatever you
would get attention you would
acknowledge them you would focus on them
for a second but not everybody in the
school was like i'm gonna start doing
that right they're like those people are
freaks y'all and now we've got this on a
national global scale how many of the
kids how many people i have to think
that my kids if they happen to come
across this crap on social media which
they're not on very often
is maybe they're just like yeah whatever
i'm looking at it i'm laughing at it i'm
pointing at it but are they really
inspired to do it some seem to be in
2006 i started making youtube videos
2006 you'd get the occasional random
person that's like i'm gonna dump
spaghetti sauce on my head in a video to
get attention and it would be really
weird and you'd be like okay i'm not
going that direction
and then more and more and more as the
years went on you started to see this
like larger percentage of the mass
adopting that behavior not a lot more
but it seems to be like a small growth i
mean obviously the behaviors
you know i think we're interested in
watching car crashes we like the 600 i
don't like it but people like the 600
pound life kind of thing they like
watching these things maybe as a way to
other to other that and to be like i'm
not that it's it people hey pt barnum
figured this out he took people all
around the country to come see and do
traveling shows to see a bearded lady
the girls that came and saw that didn't
walk home from there and be like i can't
wait to grow a beard they're like that's
crazy yeah but what if instead of having
you go to what's what you're told is
literally the freak show
it is a bunch of people walking around
your town being celebrated and cheered
for and it's a woman with a big long
beard and she's posing and everyone's
like oh bravo bravo rewarded and paid
when these guys were these kids go on
tick tock and they see the lady going
like oh yeah and she's putting spaghetti
on the counter they see a million views
they see a million likes they see people
sharing and talking about they go i want
that yeah i agree that this is a problem
to some degree but i also know that for
example my son watches like
weightlifting and fitness and like inspo
videos on tick tock and on instagram and
he comes back and he's like i'm going to
do squat tober he comes back and he's
like i'm going to eat this many calories
i'm going to get fit and i'm going to
get stronger i'm not saying the kids are
going to start pouring waiting on their
counter
saying that they're going to start
thinking that's real they're going to
believe it's real so your son believes
squat tober's a real thing yeah what if
some guy was just like dude i'm going to
get a bunch of you know bros to retweet
my stuff by claiming their squat tober
and it's not a real thing now that's
fine exercise is fine but what they're
doing is disgusting and off-putting yeah
and it's intentional i mean a better
example is literally jesse smilette
people believed him they wanted to
believe him i think smart people and
older people like mature people didn't
and don't
but people do well people say we're
living right now in an attention economy
and i really think uh previous people
long time ago like paris hilton kind of
paved the way for this where they
created controversy they had people
talking about them and because of that
they got a lot of fame and attention the
kardashians i think are also known for
doing that creating controversy creating
attention getting everyone to look at
them when they look at them they're like
hey buy this and buy this and they get
rewarded they get paid for this we also
have to understand this attention
economy is just like the food economy
there's a lot of fast food out there and
it's digitized and it's produced by
major corporations and it's sold to you
for super cheap and there's also high
quality stuff like jack was talking
about
about people bettering themselves
working out but that takes a lot of
consideration that takes a lot of work
that takes a lot of investment than just
the cheap fast food that's readily
available the the blue armpit haired
crazy person shoving things up their
nose and declaring that their pony is is
that cheap fast food in my opinion from
my perspective it also needs guidance
because if you as a kid see both those
the the cheap fast food crap and the
good the good squat stuff and you don't
know what's what you might not you might
pick one well when kids are raised on
that fast food bull crap that's all they
they they know that's what their system
is is used to taking in that's what
they're going to be obviously taking and
that's what their system is going to
want i'll do one final thought on the
justice millet thing i don't think he
cares about politics i don't think he
cares about trump i don't think he cares
about any of the cultural issues i think
he was like how can i raise my profile
and that's what he did thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time